so at the end of last night's show right
at the end we told you that the dwarf
king might be
vacating his musky lair over at cnn
turns out we were right this morning
jeff zucker informed his bewildered
minions at the disgraced cable channel
that in fact he is leaving at the end of
this year and honestly
we're gonna miss him in a business
filled with blustery half-wits zucker
was absolutely the blusterist
if that's a word you cannot be elected
president of the united states without
cnn
he's once boasted to his felon lawyer
buddy michael cohen on a tape we brought
you a few months ago
hilarious it's kind of hard to beat that
level of entertainment with your pants
on we didn't even have to watch cnn to
enjoy it
but it's also worth remembering jeff
zucker's other contribution to the
american media landscape
jeff zucker's relentless attacks on the
freedom of speech
zucker created an entire unit at cnn
devoted to shutting down any news
organization that refused to toe the
ruling class line
if you had unauthorized questions about
anything
jeff zucker wanted to force you to be
quiet and he tried
zucker staffed his own little ministry
of truth with two of the most
repulsive yet obedient imposters he
could find political activists posing as
reporters
thugs pretending to be objective
analysts he set them loose to silence
free
thinking journalists with threats lies
and bullying
in a number of cases they have been
successful a tragedy every time
cnn is in fact trying its best to pull
this show and fox itself
off the air for good harm reduction
that's what they call it
as if fox news was a deadly pathogen
that is not the behavior of a legitimate
news organization but it's exactly what
cnn has become
a tv channel that makes billion a
billion dollars a year
using the first amendment to kill free
speech in the rest of the media
that's wrong but it's not just wrong
it's frightening you don't want to live
in the country cnn is creating but jeff
sucker has not done this alone
going forward we want to be a lot more
specific and much more detailed about
who
is trying to strip you of your most
valuable birthright as an american
which is the freedom to speak and hear
the truth
everything is based on that and you
should know the names of the people
trying to take it away
you should know why they're trying to do
it you should understand the stakes
we want to begin tonight briefly because
we're going to have a lot more time
in the coming weeks and months because
it's important but we want to begin
tonight with jeff zucker's boss a man
called john stanky
now john stanky runs at t which owns cnn
stanky knows what jeff zucker does at
cnn and he strongly approves of it
last year stanky announced that zucker
was doing quote a wonderful job
at the channel and you should be
concerned about that
at t is an enormously powerful company
in 2019
its net income was nearly 14 billion
dollars
more ominous att controls over a million
miles of
fiber lines chances are virtually
everything you know about the outside
world flows through
a t's property so john stanky's opinions
matter
he has an awful lot of control over your
life john stanky thinks it's okay to
silence the show to silence you
why does john stanky think that we would
very much
love to ask him but in the meantime we
will keep digging and we're going to let
you know
what we find